two times Super Bowl champion that's
Malcolm Jenkins joined protests in
Philadelphia after the death of George
Floyd at the hands of police in an
emotional social media posts estates
players spoke out against teammate Drew
Brees after he criticized those who
kneeled during the national anthem Brees
has since apologized here's a look what
Malcolm had to say the other day I'm
disappointed I'm hurt because why the
world tells you that you're not worthy
that your life doesn't matter the last
place you want to hear from are the guys
that you that you go to war with and
that you consider to be allies and to be
your friends boy Malcolm Jenkins used to
play for the Philadelphia Eagles and is
a founder of listen up media he joins us
now from Philadelphia Malcolm it is so
good to see you and I want to just hit
that tape for just a second cuz I really
appreciated your tears a day it's not
just I a lot of people do because most
men certainly men such as yourself big
and strong two-time Super Bowl winners
don't show that kind of vulnerability
but clearly it was important to you and
I think it touched people in a way and I
think people heard your way heard your
words in a way that they hadn't before
what are your thoughts now about that
day and looking at looking back at the
reaction yeah I'm glad that I chose to
post that video I posted it I recorded
that video before and drew actually
reached out to me before I could post it
and we had that same conversation that
are the same things I said in a video I
said to Drew Brees but I thought that it
was important that our country
understand you know the pain that black
people have been dealing with and then
black people carry around I think we're
in that moment where we need truths
before we have reconciliation and I was
an
paternity for me to share my truth not
only to Drew Brees but to you know
everybody who's watching well Roger
Goodell apparently was one of the people
who was watching and he has since
reversed his position saying the NFL
hasn't gotten it right
is that enough what do his words mean to
you now I still I still don't think
they've gotten a right until they
apologized specifically to Colin
Kaepernick or sign him to a team I don't
think that they'll end up on the right
side of history at the end of the day
they have listened to their players
they've donated money they've created
inspired change platform they've tried
to do things up into this point it's
been one player in particular that they
have not already they've ignored and
have not acknowledged and as Colin
Kaepernick yeah was that the big
elephant in the room that Colin
Kaepernick wasn't mentioned in the in
Roger Goodell statement I think so yeah
that's the only thing that that people
want to hear you know if it is not going
to correct that or acknowledge that you
know then everything else you know it
doesn't need to be said what are the
chances that you think that Colin
Kaepernick will be playing in the NFL
the NFL can say look we offered him an
opportunity to be on a team what are the
chances now that you think that will
happen I mean I don't know I can't
speculate to that but I think the first
step is just acknowledging one his
contribution to all of the issues that
we see going on now and all the the
demonstrations that we see and that's
the biggest thing just acknowledge it
and apologize do you think more NFL
players Malcolm will begin to kneel at
the football games during the anthem I'm
sure there are guys that are more
motivated than ever to to get involved
whether that's through protest or
or through advocacy their own charities
I think there's definitely going to be a
larger participation from athletes just
in social activity in general
now that translates into kneeling
approach
dawnie anthem all those things I think
that's yet to be seen yeah but you you
know Malcolm there's still people that
don't get it that are still saying
you're disrespecting that people are
disrespecting the flag in the anthem
what are your words to make them
understand what this is truly about well
honestly if at this point in time in
2020 people don't understand what the
protests about dinero
they are blatantly trying to ignore it
so I try not to waste my time talking
about the anthem or thing because it's a
distraction from the actual issues that
are plaguing our black and brown
communities and things that we need to
get fixed yeah fair enough totally get
that
you were protesting in Philadelphia over
the weekend what kind of police reform
would you like to see well I think the
biggest thing that we want to see is the
D fund in front of police and and people
have you know need to understand what
that means it doesn't mean that we
eradicate police you know completely it
means that in a city like Philadelphia
which is the poorest large city in the
country you're dealing with the effects
of Cova 19 and the financial effects
with that and there's you know in our
society you've got schools that have 10
million you have 10 million kids going
to schools with police officers in them
and no social workers 3 million that got
police in their schools and no nurses 6
million with police in their schools but
no psychologists yet we want to invest
in putting more police on the streets
and over policing as we know does not
make our community safer so we'd rather
see that money go into programs that
help with entrepreneurship that help
with our schooling that help with people
who are black people who have been
disproportionately affected by co fit
and and those things that we know help
our community members that that need to
climb out of poverty and those things
help deal with Public Safety all right
Malcolm Jenkins the world is watching
your words make a difference thank you
sir for your time this morning